e
oui
nous partons aujourd'hui pour une
randonnée au coeur de la célèbre forêt
de teutoburg dans le nord ouest de
l'allemagne
là où herman le mythique chef germain
défie les légions romaines
le sentier qui porte son nom lehrman ce
fake est considéré comme l'un des plus
beaux itinéraires pédestres d'allemagne
il s'étend entre aïn aide et molds sur
156 km point de départ rhyner le nom de
ville la reynie l'appellation primitif
de la ville apparaît pour la première
fois dans des écrits au viiie siècle
alors que charlemagne tente d'annexer la
saxe il fait ériger cette cité pour se
protéger de la résistance saxon le
monastère bent la gueule est l'un des
plus beaux édifices de la ville
cet ensemble mythique datant du xvème
siècle abrite aujourd'hui un musée
d'histoire et de civilisation
aux abords du monastère les bâtiments de
la saline goûteuse gab soigneusement
restaurés témoigne de l'âge d'or du
commerce du sel en westphalie
voici notre premier compagnon de route
marc ostwald ring restaurateurs
originaire de rhein et randonneurs
chevronnés
le pays de münster est effectivement un
terrain de jeu idéal pour les
randonneurs et les cyclotouristes marais
landes prairies et champs cultivés
composent un paysage tantôt plat tantôt
vallonné au charme incontestable
le restaurant de marc ostwald ring souls
planteurs cotone est situé à elle tu cet
endroit est une affaire de famille
quatre générations se sont succédé aux
fourneaux en notre honneur il nous
prépare une de ses spécialités du boeuf
aux oignons accompagné de betteraves
rouges
une variante de notre boeuf miro ton
marcous commence par plonger la viande
dans l'eau bouillante
les betteraves sont mis à cuire dans de
l'eau salée ainsi que quelques légumes
carottes poireaux navets marcous a
préparé un rond point auquel il ajoute
les oignons émincés et leur eau de
cuisson
encore un trait de vin blanc et la sauce
à l'oignon est prête
au bout d'une demi-heure les betteraves
rouges sont à point cuits à coeur tout
en restant légèrement ferme
elles vont à présent mariner quelques
temps dans un bouillon vin rouge
assaisonné d'un bouquet garni
la viande est un produit de la région de
manière générale le chef privilégie les
ingrédients locaux et voilà le
magnifique boeuf aux oignons de marque
val tring à déguster avec une bonne
bière fraîche mentir est passée la
jonction entre le canal
and there and et le canal dortmund
health nous retournons en forêt ou des
tranches formations rocheuses semble
surgir de la végétation
ce sont les deux center clip le rocher
de la femme accroupie et le plus célèbre
d'entre eux la légende raconte qu'une
mère voulons sauver ses enfants d'une
crue terrible les prix sur ses épaules
s'est accroupi à prier quand les masses
d'eau se sont retirés elle avait été
transformée en rocher pour l'éternité
le sentier nous mène à présent dans le
pays de tekken bourgue et l'atmosphère
se fait tout de suite plus guillerette
nous sommes accueillis par une jolie
petite troupe qui rumine à qui mieux
mieux
nous voici à la ferme bio avril sauf sa
spécialité le lait de chèvre sous toutes
ses formes
le patron c'est lui
lutgen weidmann ils élèvent un troupeau
d'une cinquantaine de chevaux poules
cochons et autres dindon viennent
compléter le tableau de famille
c'est l'heure de la traite
elle a lieu deux fois par jour
pourquoi nationale sans papiers à la
ferme bio produits de délicieux fromage
de chèvre tous les jours enrobé de
cendres dervaux aromatiques diverses
marini dans de l'huile d'olive au thym
et romarin une palette de saveurs
presque infinies au gré des envies et de
l'imagination de la fromagère gaby
paille kurt c'est elle qui depuis plus
de 20 ans fabrique fromage à la ferme et
qui en a développé toutes les recettes
l'égouttage du petit-lait joue un rôle
primordial car il influe sur la qualité
et la conservation du fromage
certains fromages seront consommés frais
d'autres affiner la ferme bio house
wheels of est une étape gourmande à ne
manquer sous aucun prétexte
un régal pour les papilles autant que
pour les yeux
nous retrouvons notre fil d'ariane à
travers la forêt de teutoburg lerman
svec nous conduit à présent abadie borg
une petite ville thermale de tradition
fondée au 12e siècle le château yves
bourgain une ancienne abbaye bénédictine
en est sans doute l'un des monuments les
plus remarquables 20 km plus loin se
trouve borgoltz à ausone ici les
habitants sont particulièrement fiers de
leur musée d'histoire locale
il est installé dans une ancienne ferme
traditionnelle
classé monument historique
voici la pièce maîtresse du musée
l'atelier du photographe ludwig
schumacher né en 1871 à bourgueil sawsen
infatigable chroniqueur de sa ville
natale il immortalise dans
d'innombrables clichés
le musée présente également des toiles
d'artistes régionaux
un peu plus loin la maison schulz
confectionne une des spécialités les
plus emblématiques de l'allemagne
l'élève couronne de délicieux biscuits
de perdre et pis la pâte composée de
farine de blé d'épeautre de sucre brun
et des pisse doit reposer pendant au
moins deux jours
on lui ajoute ensuite la potasse et du
carbonate d'ammonium ce sont ces levures
qui donne la couronne son petit arômes
caractéristiques
la maison should se fabriquent des pins
des pistes depuis cinq générations pour
la forme des biscuits pas question de
déroger à la tradition dernière
opération et non des moindres le pain
d'épicés recouvert d'une ganache au
chocolat noir dont la saveur corsée et
rehaussée par les épices
l'élève couronne se déguste toute
l'année mais c'est sans nul doute au
moment des fêtes qu'ils sont les plus
appréciés ils sont les stars des marchés
de noël
l'occasion également de glisser un petit
mot doux est l'élue de son coeur
peterkin aoste dirige l'entreprise
familiale schulz lui aussi aime venir se
ressourcer sur la magnifique
le château de rheinsberg date du 12e
siècle il est arrivé jusqu'à notre
époque en très mauvais état et c'est
uniquement grâce aux dons et à
l'engagement des habitants qu'il a pu
être sauvée de la destruction
peter lloyd guide au château nous emmène
tout en haut du donjon
le donjon et la tour la plus haute d'un
château fort destiné à servir à la fois
deux points d'observation de postes de
tir et deux derniers refuges si la
fortification vient à être prise par
l'ennemi
depuis cet auteur en effet le regard
s'étend à perte de vue
de quoi faire le bonheur des visiteurs
d'aujourd'hui une petite pause au café
du château et nous reprenons notre route
nous pas nous mène à travers le pays de
ravensberg prochaine arrêt allant en
westphalie
la fondation de la ville remonte au
xiiie siècle
ah le est une charmante petite ville qui
respire la douceur de vivre de places en
ruelles les maisons anciennes rivalisent
de colombages la place de l'église le
coeur de haelen nous offre une
magnifique représentation de ce style
architectural à l'hôtel-restaurant
d'herbes ou rennes crook on peut
déguster une bonne bière faite maison
la production est modeste le brasseur et
propriétaire du restaurant en ahl
pettersson mise avant tout sur la
fraîcheur la saveur et l'authenticité de
ses bières ronald petersen effectué de
brassage par semaine
ma fraîcheur le brasseur prélèvent
régulièrement des échantillons afin de
contrôler le degré d'alcool d'humour
la microbrasserie du gouren crook
propose une bière brune plutôt épicé
mais également de la pisse la
traditionnelle bière blonde allemande
qu'on accompagne d'un petit pain au
drêche bien frais confectionné avec les
résidus de malte issus du brassage de la
bière
suite du voyage bielefeld la métropole
de l'est de la westphalie son emblème le
château de schwerin bourgue qui se
dresse majestueusement au dessus de la
ville construit au milieu du xiiie
siècle par les comptes de ravensberg la
forteresse fut souvent à siéger mais a
toujours su défendre sa ville
non
depuis sa tour le panorama sur la ville
et ses alentours est splendide
l'alt markt le vieux marché et le coeur
historique de bielefeld avec ses
demeures patriciennes de toute beauté en
bordure du centre ville la queen salle
le musée d'art moderne et contemporain
première création en europe de
l'architecte philippe johnson un élève
de miss van der hoff
notre coup de coeur gastronomique le
restaurant nicht schwimmer qui a su en
très peu de temps faire revivre un petit
quartier un peu délaissé de bielefeld
chef au restaurant depuis un an
michael straetmans a fait souffler un
vent de fraîcheur et de malice dans la
cuisine le match devant une chambre
d'une vague venture blanc marne
au menu du jour petit chèvre chaud du
techland bourgue avec une poêlée de
tomates et de poivrons
il commence par faire frire les fromages
préalablement fariné
les légumes sont mélangés un coulis de
tomate en accompagnement
michael propose des pommes de terre
rissolées au romarin le tout est servi
dans de petites cocottes en fonte
berline de saltzmann et son mari
christopher radtke sont des habitués du
nietzsche mi-mars il apprécie la cuisine
colorée et festive de michael straetmans
elle est guide touristique à bielefeld
lui est biologiste a eu deux ils sont
incollables sur le patrimoine culturel
et naturel de la ville et de ses
environs
bien entendu lerman ce fake est
régulièrement au programme de leur
balade une magnifique forêt de hêtres
déploie son feuillage dense presque
impénétrable
il s'agit d'une forêt primaire ici la
nature doit pouvoir se développer à son
propre rythme
loin de leurs nuits de son influence
quatre kilomètres plus loin se dresse
une tour panoramique construite en 1895
appelé en tonnes de fer elle fait partie
de la série des tours bismarck érigé
entre 1869 et 1934 à la mémoire du
premier chancelier impérial c'est ici
que se termine la balade de guerre linde
et christopher
quant à nous nous poursuivons notre
chemin direction hurling house home
situé au sud-est de bielefeld dans le
pays de l'ip longtemps marqué par
l'industrie du lin et les fabrique de
cigares la petite ville ouvrière s'est
muée en une agréable ville touristique
l'église évangélique réformée alexander
kirsch a date du 16e siècle
il s'agit d'une église salle qui
comporte trois nefs de taille identique
le parlando est un des meilleurs hôtels
restaurants de la ville
en 2009 il s'est vu décerner le label
qualité par l'association de leur
magnifique la cuisine du chef torsten
pabst généreuse et authentique n'y est
sans doute pas étrangère
le voici qui nous présente un plat
typique du pays de l'ip
iph 1101 rosine d'entraîneur on peut
également remplacer la farine par des
pommes de terre et le servir salle est
en tout cas un piqueur tu n'es rien sans
une bonne couche de mélasse de
betteraves à sucre
à l'origine le piqueur tu es le plat du
pauvre que les pays ils ont confectionné
avec les ingrédients les plus simples et
surtout les plus roboratif il est
aujourd'hui l'une des spécialités les
plus savoureuses de la région wehrling
saoudienne est dominée par la cre est
douteuse bergues
on y accède par un escalier qui porte le
doux nom des chaînes du paradis le
chemin débouche sur la coume stone un
ancien moulin à vent dont il ne reste
désormais plus que la tour c'est
l'emblème durling thousand il figure
même sur le blason de la ville
la forêt se fait de plus en plus tôt fut
à mesure que nous cheminons quand enfin
le voilà perché sur son promontoire sur
le manteau de bergues le valeureux
herman dominent les étendues boisées du
haut de ses 54 m c'est sans doute à cet
endroit même que s'est jouée la bataille
de tobrouk où la germanie l'emportent
sur rome donnant naissance à la nation
allemande
hermann est l'incarnation de la
résistance germanique contre les romains
érigé en 1875 herman dresse son épée en
direction de l'ouest
répondant ainsi à une autre statue de
l'autre côté du rhin celle de
vercingétorix sur le lieu supposé de la
bataille d'alésia
et s'il est au fait de ses personnages
meetic vous donnent des ailes
le parcours d'accrobranche situé à
proximité du monument d'hermann vous
permettra de prendre un peu de hauteur
au programme pont de singe saut de
tarzan pour népalais armée de
mousquetons delonge et de baudriers
partez à la conquête de la canopée
la ville de detmold est une étape
incontournable le long de l'ère van
slycke sur la place du marché se
côtoient l'église du rédempteur de style
baroque tardif et l'hôtel de ville de
style classique
le château de detmold est l'un des plus
beaux châteaux de la renaissance
allemande
sur le parvis du musée régional la chute
du cavalier de l'apocalypse de ville
free de corps
l'âme de la ville se niche dans les
quartiers anciens du centre historique
et barnier par les destructions des deux
guerres mondiales dans ces jolis ruelles
pavées
le temps semble comme suspendu detmold
possède l'un des musées de plein air les
plus importants d'europe
il s'étend sur près de 100 hectares
aménagés dans l'esprit des différentes
régions de la westphalie 90 bâtiments
regroupés en véritable village reflètent
les différents modes de constructions
rurales et le métier d'antan chaque jour
en emule grain on y forge en y façonne
dépôt comme autrefois les visites
thématiques sont l'occasion d'admirer
les jardins paysans ainsi que les
nombreuses espèces anciennes d'animaux
domestiques qui vivent paisiblement dans
les fermes
dans la boulangerie traditionnelle on re
découvre l'art de la lenteur trois
heures de chauffe sont nécessaires pour
que le four atteignent la température de
350 degrés rhyner boeing rohff et
jorgensen carte les maîtres des lieux
ont ainsi tout le loisir de façonner
avec amour toutes sortes de spécialités
boulangères et autres viennoiseries mais
dès que le four est à bonne température
il ne s'agit plus de lambiner ou n'en
fournit en outre le temps de cuisson est
très court pour y organiser c'est un
réel avantage marche
la boulangerie de l'écomusée fabrique
plus d'une centaine de pains par jour
une miche croustillante dans le sac à
dos nous reprenons notre route sans plus
tarder pour une rencontre avec des
oiseaux rares
les rapaces de l'adler vaart eux apaire
le bec
les galeries propose tous les jours des
démonstrations de vol libre et permet
aux visiteurs de voir de près ces
oiseaux fascinant cloud en zone le
directeur de la guerre var te veut
également sensibiliser le public à
l'importance de la biodiversité et de la
conservation des espèces
dans cette optique la lueur vaart eux
possède son propre centre de
reproduction et recueille les animaux
blessés
ça
tandis que l'aigle s'envole à tire
d'aile
nous entamons la dernière étape de notre
randonnée
nous avons rendez vous avec stéphane
radec l'ancien garde forestier est
aujourd'hui responsable de l'entretien
de la magnifique
il veut nous montrer un site
extraordinaire
les externes stein cinq piliers de grès
sombre aux formes étranges se découpant
sur le ciel s'élève sur une trentaine de
mètres
selon une légende populaire
ces pierres auraient été dressés en une
nuit par des géants et brûlé par le
diable les flammes de l'enfer leur
aurait donné cet aspect tourmenté on
ignore presque tout de l'origine et de
la signification des externe stein au
fil des âges certains y ont vu un lieu
d'observation astronomique d'autres un
lieu de culte païen
quand le christianisme a supplanté les
croyances païennes en allemagne la
nouvelle religion s'est approprié le
site
en témoigne cette descente de la croix
superbe bas-reliefs creusée par des
moines cisterciens à la fin du 12e
siècle plongeant entre les deux
principaux groupes de rochers le sentier
grimpe le talus et remonte vers la forêt
nous arrivons dans la vallée du ziz
berbard pour une dernière étape
gourmande les îles bermudes charmant
hôtel restaurant au coeur de la forêt de
teutoburg attend les promeneurs au bord
d'un étang foisonnant de carpes
mais si nous sommes venus ici
aujourd'hui c'est pour déguster l'une
des délicieuses spécialités de la
pâtissière martina et d'air elle est en
train de confectionner l'un de ces
gâteaux préférés
le gâteau aux pommes et aux vins blancs
la recette ne date pas d'hier
pour la garniture martin a besoin de six
à huit hommes qu'elle mélange à du vin
blanc et du jus de pomme pour lier le
tout martina ajoute un peu de poudre de
flan pâtissier
le gâteau est enfourné à 150 degrés
pendant cuisson une heure martina
prépare ensuite une délicieuse crème
dont elle recouvrira le gâteau un
ingrédient fait toute l'originalité de
la recette des graines de pavot
ado fm qu'amsterdam analyse années 70
mister moonlight
c'est magnifique
stéphane radec nous accompagne une
dernière fois pour l'ascension du fait
de mort staut de la lippe constellé de
blocs de grès
le phenom staut de prusse lui fait face
avec sa tour panoramique de 17 mètres de
haut à cet endroit
lehrman ce bug se prolonge sur un autre
sentier de randonnée les grecs qui
parcourt le massif de l'aig
le début d'une autre histoire